what a crowd I'm Rachel Williams I'm
head of diversity and inclusion at Yelp
but that is not what I'm gonna talk
about because I do have several stories
about that job I am gonna talk a little
bit about an experience I had and how it
impacted me so I'm a Bay Area girl born
and raised anybody else in the bay write
to all others welcome to our town I was
born into a really big family over 300
family members in the bay area alone
right we're Christian not more men don't
ask my parents are working-class my dad
makes parts for submarines at Northrop
Grumman my mom was a hairdresser and
like all parents they wanted the best
for me what which means better education
so they did what they had to do to make
sure that I went to the finest schools
San Mateo County could offer so that
meant being bussed from my neighborhood
to a predominantly white neighborhood
imma let you guys in on a little secret
and black families black parents have to
have a race conversation with their
children very early I've had two such
conversations with my mom the first one
five years old five years old getting
ready to go to candy garden real school
I was dressed in my red Reds my favorite
color still is red dress red pigtails I
was matching it was ready to go she
pulls me aside and she says so I just
want you to know that you're not gonna
be like all the other kids and I gave
her this look like what in the hell are
you talking about lady I'm ready to go
to school
I grabbed my strawberry short cut cake
lunch pail and like ran to the car she
said she couldn't even finish the rest
of the talk because I was like not
having any of that the second time I got
that talk was as I was entering my
freshman year in high school I went to a
very pristine
Aegeus an elite private school and a
little Enclave and outside of San Mateo
and a very prestigious neighborhood and
all of the students there had very
well-known parents and my mom says well
you're gonna go to this school because
you're gonna help bring diversity and in
exchange you're gonna get a good
education which sounds like a fair deal
to me I can be myself and get a free
education no problem
done easy-peasy so freshman year easy
making friends cuz what's not to like
about me
[Applause]
now the school part was a little bit
rough very small classes ten people in a
class so there was no way to hide that
you didn't do your homework so little
rocky but I made it through second year
sophomore year was really excited to
take this creative writing class so I
was like this is my jam I love writing
I've been writing since I was about five
years old
saved all those books guys ever want to
read him sent him around to you but this
is my thing like this is where I can
really shine so I was I'm in the class
and the class is being led by a
wonderful woman who I felt a kindred
spirit with she was lesbian and
masculine what a short haircut and very
different from the other professors at
this very prestigious private school so
I was like my girl right there I'm
different she's different like it's
gonna be great definitely gonna Ace this
class so I remember staying after class
one day and talking to her and saying
hey you know so I think I want to be a
creative writer or you know a journalist
or something and she very plainly said
to me you don't have that talent yeah
think about how I felt crushed beyond
belief because I had been writing since
the little girl with the pigtails with
the Strawberry Shortcake lunch pail so
from that moment on I stuck to just
writing my book reports
no more creative writing no more
thoughts of writing a play no more
writing poetry no more writing anything
extra I go on go to UC Berkeley Khan
fluttering right yeah go bears
fluttering around I end up with a
psychology degree again no writing
involved in that really not really a
little bit maybe
and so I'm I'm never thought again about
about writing because you don't have
that talent is just ringing in my ears
so I'm in this job
head of diversity and inclusion at Yelp
and it affords me the opportunity to
speak to crowds like this and I was at
South by Southwest last year chatting
and talking about well diversity and
inclusion and a publisher came up to me
afterwards and said I think I think like
you can't you should write a book
haven't you heard I don't have that
talent I can't do that so I was
flattered beyond belief right because
that's my ultimate dream to write it's
what I've always wanted to do but I
don't think that's my jam anymore really
stick to this public speaking thing this
diversity inclusion belonging equity
equality thing activism you know that's
my jam now I don't want to write about
that so um I'm at my local Whole Foods
over in Oakland and I'm doing my huge
you know in the line chatting with
everybody bah bah bah bah bah what did
you get have you tried this and I see
this gray-haired woman with the very
short haircut and masculine build and
she's chatting me up she's like hey you
look familiar
do you work here no I don't
but I'm here very often I'm a loyal
customer maybe you've seen me around
yeah maybe that's it so we're leaving
she's walking we're going out and she's
still chatting me up you know like she
can't place my face and I could see her
racking her brain where does she know me
from so we get to the parking lot and
she's telling me about the car she just
bought and her son and she had just
moved back here and I don't know if it
was the turn in her face or what it was
but it dawned on me that that was that
professor from my high school who told
me I did not have that talent right this
is the moment I have been waiting for
like I'm gonna tell this woman what's up
so I said um did you ever teach a class
and uh San Mateo County and brown 1990
I'm not gonna tell the rest cuz you guys
she was like yes I said well I was one
of your students and not a very good
student according to you and she said oh
I wouldn't even remember that and it was
at that moment I realize that her words
had such an impact on me change the
trajectory of my career but I had no
impact on her so lesson do not let
anybody tell you what you can and cannot
do nobody nobody
secondly mind your own words be careful
what you say to other people because you
don't know how they're gonna impact a
child or someone's dreams so I told her
I said well funny that we're meeting
because I was just approached by a
publisher to write a book and it's gonna
be coming out in 2018 what's your
address I'll send you a copy
[Applause]
so be on the lookout for my book coming
soon thank you
[Applause]